chronic knuckle cracking can cause  stretching in the surrounding ligaments  while this may decrease grip strength it  won't cause arthritis there are many  conspiracy theories that suggest  companies lace their products with  addictive substances but lip balm is  habit-forming  and not addictive mini lip balms contain  salicylic acid petroleum jelly lanolin  and peda mate  none of these substances are addictive  your your referral sphincters make it  physically impossible to build up your  bladder to the point of rupture causing  the person to eventually pee the air  from sneezes can travel up to 100 miles  per hour holding a sneeze can  potentially cause fractures in the nasal  cartilage nose bleeds  burst eardrums vertigo hearing loss or  temporary swelling  you